Charlize Theron's who is single and
she's all good with that her new Netflix
movie the old guard is streaming
tomorrow and trust me when I tell you
there is nothing old about Charlie's on
or off the screen damn it you're not
aging so you feel like one of these
folks is it mortal forever oh you are so
sweet I still consider myself pretty
young somebody said yet you know the
thing I love the most about this movie
is that you pick the perfect age to
become immortal you've got questions kid
I get it and I thought basically what
you're saying is that the perfect age
for a woman to freeze that is 45 and
I'll take that and we should be changing
that and making it 50 and 55 and 60 and
let's keep going with it so how exactly
does the 44 year old mom of 2 look
ageless sunblock every day facials every
three weeks and a plant-based diet but
Charlize is new Netflix movie the old
guard is a whole new level of commitment
she's the hardcore leader of this
international cast
I mean Amsterdam with my family in
Cincinnati when Lee you can is hot today
what was it like making this movie and
watching all the physicality especially
with Charlize and Kiki fantastic I love
what Charlize does with physicality in
all of her film he would do something
like an action sequence for 35 pounds if
it's necessary just to get one detail
right yeah what was the training like
for you guys I think we were training
3-4 hours different types of training
and we did that for four to five weeks
when I look at the movie now and how
incredible the action is in in this film
and how we've raised the bar with a lot
of the action set-pieces it's amazing to
me that we all walked away that
unscathed how was it for you nothing
that scared me away from doing more
action you're in now don't say that this
woman will grab you come on now I'll go
where she wants to take me I think she
has potential the action-packed movie
about a group of immortal mercenary
starts dreaming Friday but what kick
Charlize is but during quarantine home
school I am such a brand new
appreciation and respect for teachers I
can't just safely reopen having your
children for 24 hours a day is it's
pretty full-on for sure
[Music]